bht ある
car
はぁ
ています
ha
マッハ
pou dou dou
ありません
バッハ
た
あっあっはい
ん
はぁ
にしないよ
ん
goo
me
rem
ni を
me
ミュー外パブ見たスパイスで緊急
を
ん
ブーレーズん
me
は
重大なんで
ん
me
運命しまってアプ貼ってやるマイあるんで
r
ふーん
r 2
ん
par 2
わー
ん
うううう
goo
ああああああ
ありがとうございますただいま皆様にご覧いただきましたダンスは
即興のサブ品です
ただし
少しだけ
ストラクチャーつまり
ルールがありました
それはまるで私たちが生活する社会のようでもあります
構成された中での即興性
私たちがより面白くて素敵なコンタクトインプロヴィゼーションダンスをするために
日頃心がけていることがあります
それは
100%の主張と
100%の協調を
100%の時間
行う
ということです
つまり
あらゆる人員といろんな社会もしくは人と人の関わりに全てにそれを応用できるんじゃ
ないかと考えています
主張しつつも強調する
あるいは強調しながらも視聴を通せる
100%の主張と100%の強調
100%の時間
難しいですねそれってはいどうでしょう皆さん可能ですか
しゃべると同時に聴いてるのをずっとやっているということなんです
しゃべると同時に聞いてのずっとやってるみんなが
まあこれは可能かどうかっていうよりは
それを目指すということです
それを目指すんですね難しいけれどもそれを目指す
ぜひ
お試しくださいお試しください
このことを私たちはご提案いたします
ちょっとを取った後ですので息を建前ながら喋るの家
これもまたチャレンジかなど高即興性なんですけれども
ではここで実際にやってみましょう
怒りますかやりますからやっハイあのちょっと関金キチキチなっておりますので
なかなか難しいかと思いますがもしあっお隣の人とやってみようかなぁと思ったら
試してみてくださいでそうでなければあののちほどこっそりやってみてください
はいとっとといきます2人の人がまず
contact つまりふれあいのポイントを持ちますこのような感じです
そしてそこに遠慮なく重さを誘いで言ってください
おしくらまんじゅうあるいはお相撲という感じですね
配送さんのような感じで
ハイタッチあるとよくわかります day
相手に対して自分の重さを遠慮なく注ぐと同時に地球の中心に向かっても重さを注いで
いきます
そうするとですね私の注いだ重さが地球とパートナーから力となって帰ってきて私を
支えてくれるんです
すると
なんということでしょう
楽です
皆さん椅子がここに見えますねここに椅子があって私たちは座っている状態自分に入っ
た本が後ろのお客様が見えない皆さんのため肺炎はスねイース
見えませんけど
そうです
pekoe エネルギーがくるくる循環して自分に戻ってきて
リサイクルなんですね爪でもやってるので誰が止めていただかないと
疲れないのでいつまでも続けることができるエコロジーですね
ねぇ
て a さらにですね一人ができないことができるんです
プーラー
いいかなただいないと倒れるをあなたがいたからこれができているみたいなことですね
つまり
シェアすっ
ということですね
なによりもあの
触れ合う裏ってます触れ合うということが温かくて
柔らかく体
力強い
ます
ai
voodoo 2
おった